for
good evening and
welcome to this meeting of the planning
committee and welcome to everyone
watching online if the firearm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs please do not use the lifts
please assemble in h Square on the green
officers will assist and you and advise
when it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber does anyone intend to film the
meeting okay I would advise that
speakers using the microphones are
picked up by the cameras recording the
meeting members of the public in the
public Gallery behind the speakers may
be picked up by those cameras and have
their image captured any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to move or leave the
meeting would everyone present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls or messages
in the chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress that includes me I have to do
mine um I have the following members who
wish to speak under Council procedure
20.1 items four and 5 C councel
bambridge and item 5 C counselor Smith
would any other me
and four as
well that was the next bit would any
other members who wish to speak under
Council procedure 20.1 please announce
it now we've just done that the
following applications have been
reserved for public speaking item 5A 22
St peters's Park Road item 5 C land
adjacent of 198 Monon Road monton Street
sorry and item 5G vattenfall land at
Port of Ramsgate Royal Harbor approach
Ramsgate I have three apologies from
councilors councelor brigh councelor
iseki and councelor Moore are there any
other
apologies no are there any Declarations
of Interest councelor
Orban yes chair um I'm declaring an
interest in item 5A Jackie Baker's
recreational ground as because I'm the
cabinet member responsible and I've had
quite inputs into the um in what's in
front of you this evening thank you
chair thank you do members agree that
the minutes of the planning committee
meeting held on the 15th of November
2023 be approved as a correct record and
do I have a proposer first please
councelor Auburn I just to thank you
thank you councelor Auburn I have a
proposal of councilor bayford and the
seconder council
rakan okay do members agree now you can
agree thank you okay um I'm just going
to hand over to um the planning
applications manager for a point of
information
please thank you chair um the point of
information with regards to item 5B
little cliffan farm Chalk Hill Ramsgate
it this item has been deferred to next
week's extraordinary planning committee
meeting held on the 19th of December uh
this is due to a clerical error as the
notification for public speaking was not
sent to the correct address for clifm
Parish Council thank you
chair thank you um moving on to agenda
item four speaking under Council Rule 21
I have two counselors starting with
councelor Banbridge you have three
minutes thank you chair um okay it's
item
four who oh sorry
item four is who Farm okay um as per
your as per your planning report a
retrospective planning consent is being
sought for the foot path um that has
been created my brackets instead of the
foot path that is supposed to be there
it is noted that this version of the
foot path is not intended for adoption
by KCC it would be gated but unlocked
with signage informing users that whilst
the path is privately owned and
maintained is available to all our
arguments are that the original footpath
is the same width but that's pretty much
where the similarities end those that
went to the site visit would have seen
how it the path New Path is all over the
place compared to the original proposed
path um the original approved path was
subject to safety conditions and was
compliant with KCC standards the New
Path does not meet these standards and
those that went to the site visit would
have seen that the public with um
disabilities could have problems um with
those slopes with that slope the
original approved path was intended for
use by the public and there would be
maintained by the council whereas the
New Path is now private so there is no
one taking responsibility for its upkeep
and safety standards hence the objection
about who has public liability for this
path what happens if there's an accident
the original approved path for for the
public would be maintained during the
site visit the path seemed to have been
cleared but it's been overgrown all
summer so not representative of what has
been the case normally the new private
path open to the public at their own
risk doesn't have anyone officially
maintaining it and we ECT will end up
overgrown again in no time hence
attracting enforcement issues against a
long departed developer the original
approv path was just that an approved
path um subject to standard suitable for
the public the New Path has just been
cobbled together to suit the convenience
of the developer um my question is what
is the point of having a planning
officer procedures planning officer
procedures if a developer can just
override them and do what they want I
would ask that this retrospective
application is rejected and that the
original path is constructed as agreed
and um put back in the public domain for
the use safety and well-being of our
residents thank
you thank you councelor
Smith thank you thank you chair and
um well first of all what council of
bambridge
said in addition i' like to emphasize
the point that if this path is not a
adoptable and is not
adopted then it does not serve the
interests of the community in
Minster it does not perform its purpose
it does not deliver what the people of
Minster
deserve the people of Minster
are
inundated I think by new developments by
new build developments they
have
accommodated excuse the pun but they
accommodated hundreds of
new uh new
houses and the least that this developer
can offer is a footpath that enables the
people of Miner to to Traverse the
distance between Minster and Monon it's
not safe to
replace the planned and approved path
with an unadoptable path it's just it
doesn't serve the
purpose
um and I think I think that's all I need
to say on on this particular application
that I do move that this application
be rejected because it does not Serve
the People the existing residents as
well as the new residents thank
you thank you I will now pass to the
planning applications manager to present
the
report thank you
chair um so this was an application that
was debated at last month's planning
committee that members have been to the
site visit for uh the application is uh
part retrospective permission for uh the
footpath that's been
constructed in the location shown in red
on the the plan uh with additional
requirements for Gates and signage to be
installed so previously it was a
requirement of the application in 2019
for 23 houses the permission required um
that a 1.2 M foot paath along monton
Road was constructed between points X
and Y on the plan in front of members
now um subsequent to the permission
being granted the applicant states that
the from um information from the land
registry and also uh Kent Highway's own
adoption records uh that the highway
Verge or assumed Highway Verge Corridor
connecting those two points uh was
actually unregistered uh the applicant
states that to be able to gain control
of that land they would have had to show
12 years evidence of Maintenance of the
Cor which neither the land owner which
is the adjacent farmer or indeed the
developer was not able to show and
therefore uh the footpath was
constructed not in the location shown on
the plan in front of members along the
highway but it was constructed the other
side of that unregistered land um
running from the Housing Development to
join into the um the foot paath um on to
the east of the
site so um members walked the footpath
um we've got a few photos just showing
the footpath as
constructed um so this is a width of of
1.2
M as stated and then this is where um it
runs down to join into the existing foot
path which runs along the red the rest
of the road joining uh monton and
Minster so uh as part of the
application KCC highways have been
consulted
they've stated that they would require
they've suggested the provision of gates
um and signage um which the sign which
would include the owner's contact
details and also they were requiring a
condition with regards to maintenance of
the foot path and vegetation clearance
um now there is uh there are two
conditions that relate to both of those
elements so conditions proposed two and
three two states that within two months
of the date of the permission or any
permission uh full details of the
proposed Gates and signage including
wording as indicated on the drawing
which would identify the management
company that is responsible for
maintaining the spaces within the
Housing Development would be responsible
for any issues with the foot path so
that also includes some of the points
that been raised not just in terms of
Maintenance the foot path and vegetation
clearance but also insurance so that
would be the responsibility of the
dedicated management company for the
roads within the housing development um
some of the other points that were
raised on the site visit related to um
the sort of access over the footpath
itself um that's part of condition two
sorry condition three which requires
that it should be kept available for
public use the footpath as well as that
um footpath has been constructed on the
farmers Freehold land um and but the
applicant has an easement in perpetuity
for the whole footpath to be for it to
be constructed and then subsequent to
that to be
maintained so the condition with regards
to the gates uh allows for some um
judgment with regards to the actual
details of the gates themselves that
would be um installed um specifically we
would be looking for two-way opening
easy latch Gates so they could be used
for uh those potentially in mobility
scooters with walking sticks Etc um
which is uh which Accords with normal
accessibility standards when you're
looking at Gates within rural areas um
so
overall in terms of the considerations
for members um officer view is that the
impact on the character and appearance
of the area from the footpath is is not
um is is not significantly harmful uh to
actually install the footpath itself
which has occurred uh the route itself
um is considered to be safe uh and acts
to link the footpath that you can see at
the end here in this photo to the
Housing Development uh and subject to
the conditions uh it would Accord with
the requirements of KCC highways uh and
therefore is recommended for approval
thank you
chair thank you um I move that the
officer's recommendation is approved can
someone please second it councelor
matter face thank
you and now I'm going to open up for
debate can I take councelor Garner first
and then I'll take councelor Kean thank
you thank you yeah I went went on the
site visit there was a there was a
member of the public on the site visit
whose name I can't remember but he asked
an interesting question which I I don't
think we got to the bottom of I mean it
does it does uh refer to the reason why
the football wasn't built in the
original place that it was meant to be
built and as I understand it it wasn't
built where it was meant to be built
because ownership of that land precluded
it being built there but I didn't quite
understand if ownership of that land
precluded anything being built on
it we were the developer was able to
cross the land with a driveway into the
development site so I was just wondering
if the developer was able to get that
permission why wasn't he able to get
permission to do the rest I mean maybe
it was just that short stretch of land
where the foot path was meant to be um
the other question I or the other
concern I have is relating to these
Gates because the gates seem to be
actually making what is at the moment a
pretty
unsatisfactory uh alternative to what
would have been built totally
unsatisfactory it they're adding
obstacles rather than rather than making
it safe it's adding to Danger as far as
I could see I mean it's all right for
people who who can walk up and down
quite ably cuz they can just go around
the gates but people in a using sticks
or in a Mobility Scooter are going to
struggle to get through the gates it
would be a lot easier if the gates
weren't there as far as I'm concerned
right thank
you thank you ch um yeah I'm afraid I
don't have in terms of the photo you can
see I don't have the information about
where the unregistered land is and
obviously we are having to you know
having to look at the merits of The
Proposal as it is um um how we've got to
where we've got to isn't isn't part of
the determination as such in terms of
the gates specifically and and your your
comment about that that is something
obviously that has been raised as a
concern about you're creating more of an
obstacle um the applicant has stated
that they've proposed the gates because
KCC asked for it um and obviously we
have sort of followed through on what KC
have suggested um in terms of if members
felt that actually that the foot path
itself without the gates but with the
signage would be acceptable that is an
option to basically remove the gates
from the conditions which would then
mean that just the signage would be
provided the signage is the point that
is raising the the liability issue um
and actually would obviously outline who
to contact in the event of any problems
with the footpath in terms of its
maintenance or vegetation or indeed if
there was any incident at all so the
signage does that purpose um uh on that
side of things thank you
chair councilor
ke thank you chair um I did go on the
site visit and I'm glad I did because it
made an awful lot of difference um from
just seeing the photos to how I saw it
on the day particularly as it was quite
an icy day so it was also a bit slippery
out um the foot path to me seemed fine
and it seemed a very safe route um
although it's not ideal in that it does
undulate a little bit then just further
up from that photo is a much steeper
Hill so a bit of undulation on that foot
paath is is not going to be a problem
for people in mobility Scooters or that
if they can manage the next Hill as well
it was also very interesting that we've
talked about vegetation overgrowth but
on the day we saw it where the KCC path
takes over it was actually more
overgrown so the space you had to walk
was very narrow so you know so long as
this path is maintained of vegetation
this may well do better than the next
part also the other side of this photo
there's no path at all on the road so
all in all I see this as a valuable part
of the development that actually makes
the route safer my concern is the gates
because they seem just really quite
strange in that they're not at the
bottom um of the slope before the
lampost you can see there they're up
that bit of a slope so someone has got
to go up that bit of a slope and then
manage to open the gate and close it
behind them go along the straight foot
path do the same the other end and to me
that made it more dangerous and
certainly less accessible for people
with buggies or in
um you know Scooters or what have you um
and therefore I'm very glad to hear
what's been said tonight that there is
an option to consider whether we can do
without the the gates my uh question
about that would be what are the
implications for us as a planning
committee if we did go against what's
being recommended by KCC and say that
you know we wanted to approve it as it
was but without the gates thank
you thank you chair um
so KCC highways are a consult te um the
we have been in slightly rare
circumstances sometimes where
applications have been objected to by
KCC and we have bought them to committee
uh and recommended approval of them
because um you know there's there's a
either a disagreement or indeed that
there are merits that outweigh whatever
it is that casc have objected to um
obviously members are aware of what KCC
have said it doesn't mean
that um members can't choose to to
change you know to go against that
recommendation in this instance um you
know I would always advise that if if
case is here
recommending um approval of something I
wouldn't suggest it's refused because
obviously having the highway Authority
behind any refusal is really really
important this appeal in this instance
obviously it's a partial change to what
they've asked for um and I think that
there is a justification in terms of
what they're really trying to ident ify
within their comment it's to it's to
really make it clear that this is a this
is on private land it's not on adopted
KCC highway so they therefore they
aren't liable and the signs would do
that thank you
chair thank you if members don't mind um
I would also like to uh comment um on it
uh having seen it um the the reality is
where that the green Verge is I think is
not going to be viable for for a path
not least because of the um landine
registry issue but because there are
three lamp posts in the middle of it
that would have to have kcc's agreement
to move um which would be another issue
to deal with um the gates really are at
the top of little slopes um and it's not
realistic to put them at the bottom um
on the basis that we would be looking at
uh well the developers be looking at
180° swing so that they could be pushed
open for example by people with uh
mobility issues um what that mean what I
had the imagination of when we talked
about electric wheelchairs last time um
was someone at the top of of a little
slope pushing forcing open a gate with
their electric wheelchair and then
careening down the slope um and
similarly uh looking upwards trying to
to get the gate open from a a looking
upwards perspective um I think that the
gates are dangerous um if they are
installed and if KCC are adamant that
the gates have to be there then I would
be requesting a disability access
assessment of some kind um I would
suggest at the uh point of the crossing
of the farm entrance which is not the
the one that we have on the screen here
but the next entrance further down that
um instead there would be rumble strips
uh which would act as a marker for
anyone with um visibility issues so yeah
that one there in the middle the other
thing I I wanted to ask because I
realized when I saw the photograph and
the plan is that the path hasn't been
completed because the final the path
ends where it says proposed gate with
signage on the left and then it turns
into um gravel and doesn't go up around
the corner like it suggests it will in
the plan and so are there any intentions
to complete the path to cover the area
where it was um so so and the other
thing is um as councilor Keen has said
uh we we had to um go along the the KCC
adopted path to get to this path and
that in itself was a hazard and to
anyone who who thinks that KC adopting
this path I'm going to say be wary of
what you wish for however on that basis
um that that is clearly a strong thing
for the residents has been represented
by the the councilors um I will ask is
it possible to go back to to um KCC and
find out exactly what would be needed to
make this path
adoptable thank
you um so to come back on the question
of the foot path into the site um into
the actual Housing Development so I
think if I go to the
actual how so with the the footpath
itself um it it is planned at the end of
this B obviously this is slightly
different because this is now changed um
that it will wrap around the corner to
then allow Crossing Point into the
development obviously the the
development itself because of the low
speed movement of cars once you're in it
doesn't have a foot path either side of
that Highway all the way up that's that
slope as you go up but there will be
some further foot path that should be
constructed as part of the housing
development to wrap around in terms of
the KCC comment um specifically about
what would be need to adopt it um KCC
would be unlikely to Adopt A Highway uh
sorry a footpath that is separated from
a highway in terms of the fact that
you've got that distance between it um
from my my general understanding of it I
must admit I don't know whether or not
the issue with the gradients at
different points causes a concern for
them as well that's what's mentioned in
their comment in terms of what it would
take for them to adopt St it um I don't
know the extent of changes that would
need to be made to the existing
structure for them to do that and it may
be that because of where it is and the
fact that it's divorced from the highway
they may not do it anyway um so it's a
separate part of legislation under the
highway act so I wouldn't it's really
that would be the next step if this if
this wasn't considered to be acceptable
um what they would potentially need to
do to it I think again I don't really
want to get into the sort of either or
options it's really a case of you know
is is this as it is um you know
acceptable and just to come back on the
The Gates Again obviously a few members
have now mentioned about the gates
obviously just to remind members that
the motion that's on the table includes
the gates as it stands but obviously
we'll see what happens with the debate
in terms of if people feel that that
that should be you could be
changed thank you I have um councilor
Alburn next
please thank you chair I didn't go to
the uh site visit cuz I wasn't here so
uh but I've heard what uh the members
have been there have said I just find
that cases here got a bit bit of a cheek
to be to be quite honest laying down the
law on a private footpath that they
require these these gates to to go in
which
just it's just unheard up I mean they
won't adopt it they won't do anything
with it but they want to have a say well
I think excuse my it bugger him I think
we have the application you got the
application for the foot path let's just
deal deal with the foot path get get rid
of the gates because they're they are a
pain and they will they will be a pain
for users um because they have no
purpose they serve no purpose so uh my
my view chair is I'm in favor of of the
foot path listening to what other
councilors have been on the site was
that have said and um but without the
act the actual Gates and I'll be more
than happy to propose that should uh
should the uh current proposal fors here
thank you I've got councelor Wing next
please I I mean I find it quite strange
because I don't know how we can make a
decision because the main question and I
didn't go to the site visit but because
I was working but I did go on my own
back with my dog uh and it was a
question I asked at the last planning
meeting we don't seem to have a detailed
con
inclusive uh reason for KCC not adopting
this foot path and this is a new foot
path and it's irrelevant what's going on
around that foot path because as we
constantly said on this when we sit in
this committee we have to deal with the
application in front of us so the fact
that nearly all foot paths are not
maintained by whoever should maintain
them is irrelevant but the the one of
the key re key key problems I have is
none of us know why KCC won't adopt it
and until we know that we can't make a
decision and the other if we if we
approve this foot path then I'm really
worried we all have issues in our walls
with Wards with foot paths and alleys
particularly that are not adopted and
trying to get things done 20 or 15 or
even 5 years down the line is an
absolute nightmare because nobody will
take responsibility for that length of
foot path or alley and I think we should
we and I I would like to say we we
refuse the application and we ask KCC to
give us a detailed reason as to why they
won't adopt it and if it is it needs
flattening out then the foot path needs
flattening out uh and I cannot make a
decision because I don't have the the
the a clear reason for KCC not adopting
it and I think if we approve this foot
path we're stoking up problems for the
residents of Minster further down the
line thank you chair um just to come
back back on a couple of those points
the planning permission can't require
highways to be adopted so it's a really
important point there there's no because
it's under a separate bit of legislation
under the highway act so whilst there
was a condition that required a footpath
to be constructed in the location shown
there's no requirement for that to have
been adopted by
KCC so in terms of refusing an
application on the basis that KCC won't
adopt it wouldn't stand up scrutiny
because it's under separate legislation
that that process is
enacted so the the Judgment has to be is
what's there considered to be of
detriment to highway safety now if that
is the case going to want to come back
um then then that is the decision that
members members can make if it's
considered that it's it's unsafe for
pedestrians um but in terms of a
requirement for it to be adopted that's
not something um that is the determining
factor with regards to the planning
decision you know in terms of the the
officer
recommendation I need to come back
because in order to make an an educated
decision you need all the facts and it
may not be a planning decision that that
we you we can't refuse it because we
don't be because it's not in the
legislation that something has to be
adopted I feel I've been led to believe
that one of the reasons there is an
issue with this foot path is KCC won't
adopt it and I I can't sit here here and
say that I have been given by the
planning department a clear reason as to
why KCC won't adopt that foot path and
it seems to be the one thing that's
creating all the issues so although it's
not a planning reason it is critical to
to decision
making I just want to come back I'm just
going to read from the highway comment
um which is stating that U from the from
the officer having visited the site is
evident that the footpath is not
constructed to adoptable standards due
to its alignment and levels so
specifically as mentioned the alignment
is is you know the the fact that it's
separated from the highway and that it
runs as it does the levels is exactly
what we've talked about the gradients
that have changed and the cber the side
so it is that is the primary concern I
think that's is really important that is
the the concern about the safety aspect
of things and obviously that's why it's
useful that members obviously have
walked it and and seen what it's like
and that's that's what the Judgment has
be based on thank you chair I've got
councelor bayford
next thank you chair I'm afraid I was
away at the time of the site office as
well so I'm listening with interest to
what members have to say I had no
problem with the footpath itself at the
last meeting but I I do believe that the
points raised about the gates are cogent
and I think perhaps if there is an a
possible alternative to um to ask KCC to
remove that requirement
that would be very very useful thank
you councilor
matterface just out of Interest the road
on the actual development is that a
private road I.E maintained by the
people who live in the
houses yes that's correct it's part of
the management company would also
oversee the foot
path kind of just quickly so the people
who live there will presumably pay to a
management company to maintain the road
on the development and to maintain this
footpath is that right yes that's
correct do I have any other comments or
questions in that case then um we need
to go to the vote so I put the officer's
recommendation for approval as it stands
to the vote all those in
favor and those
against that is lost thank you
okay councilor Orbin you indicated just
now that you would want to um make
proposed motion yes chair and I I
propose that we uh approve the
application with the amendment that the
gates are not part of that
application and even listening to what
Mr Livingston and what councelor Wing
has has just said uh for it to go back
to officers to ensure that
KCC uh removed their
um requirement of the gates and they ac
they accept that although think now
sorry it's just I'm sparking back in
again now that really you know we don't
need kcc's
consent can I can I just come and have a
just to come back on that before I
appreciate you'll need a second of for
the motion but just to confirm um
members can approve it and change the
planning conditions we don't need to get
kcc's approval to do that so if the
motion was so it' be to approve subject
to the conditions but removing in those
conditions the requirement to construct
the gates most ay put Mr Livingston
thank you very
much could could I just ask for a point
of clar clarification over the removal
of the gates clearly KCC have said those
Gates need to be there under to
demarcate the area so that people know
that that area is not covered by KCC if
we as a committee make override KCC and
make the decision to remove those G Ates
who then becomes
liable so the in terms of the signage
which identifies who is liable on that
land that's what the signage is is is
effect is stating it it will do and
that's the requirement of condition two
even even if it were to be updated again
it's still only one proposal we haven't
had that seconded just to be clear about
the motion um but the the actual
requirement for the um for the actual
signage itself Sor I was lost lost my
condition there we go um yeah condition
two has to include basically uh
basically have to submit within two two
months the details of the wording to go
on the signage itself which then is
already stated to include basically who
is liable being the management company
that we mentioned so in terms of any
liability and effectively I mean come
back to the committee um it's very it's
going to be very apparent through that
condition who is liable for anything
that occurs on that land and who's
responsible for that
land
Council Orbin would you accept from me
as a member of the committee uh an
amendment to your motion to include the
rumble strips at the Crossing with the
farm
entrance right so can I
have I just want to clarify because I
think something that Mr livon said
earlier did
help I think helped me clarify things
but I just want to check my
understanding is what you said KCC want
this signage on there because they
aren't prepared to adopt it because they
feel it is
unsafe I think that's what you said no
no I wouldn't say they've stated they
haven't stated in their comment which is
it's in the committee report they
haven't said it's unsafe they said they
wouldn't adopt it and that that's not
the same it's not one or the
other
second right I need a seconder for the
motion Council
Kean so do you want to clarify yes so
I'm now going to ask uh Mr Livingstone
to read the final
motion okay um so the
motion uh would be to approve the
application subject to safeguarding
conditions being uh enforced but updated
to remove the requirement to provide the
gates under conditions one and two and
also to include um rumble strips uh at
points of
access for against all those in
favor any against
thank you that is
carried okay moving on to agenda item
five um any site visits will take place
for committee members on the morning of
Friday the 5th of January
2024 um and the first item is uh for
discussion is item 5A St Peters 22 St
Peters Park Road speaking against the
application I have m Katie Hooper and
you have three
minutes thank you I'm neutral to the
application but we've been in business
20 years at broadstairs mot Center which
is at 20 St Peters Park Road it's a
Bosch Car Service garage and we have
high levels of vehicle movements asot
servicing and repairs um we've made a
number of comments um to the planning
applications that haven't been addressed
so I just would like to gain some
clarity on that and to ensure that
things are in place before any
permissions are granted
um so the first of them is that we have
a steel structure at Broad st's MIT
Center and on the plans there are bin
and cycle store towards the right hand
side which borders the left hand side of
our building as you look at it um there
isn't Clarity on what vehicle ballards
are going to be in place there and the
distance from our steel structure to the
ballards that's important to us because
on the other side of that steel
structure is equipment and flammable
liquids and hazardous chemicals so it's
important that that gets addressed and
and um if the if somebody left their
vehicle in Reverse or first gear they're
going to go straight into the side of
our building so in order to know what um
whether it's going to be metal posts or
wooden barriers is quite an important
factor for us to ensure that there's the
Integrity to our building and it doesn't
compromise any safety aspects for our
staff and the building itself in terms
of the bin and cycle store um the sides
have been addressed that there is a
closure so there is an issue with p
control at the site because of the
railway station so we have Pest Control
measures in place within our
establishment however if the bin and
cycle stores are left with a recess
between our building and theirs that a
human can't get behind to access then
there's the risk of rubbish and rodents
which won't be very pleasant um there's
no mesh that goes across the top which
is what we have through a party wall
agreement with our neighbors on the
opposite side of us um so I think there
needs to be some clarity there because
the seag gos will sit on our roof and
they drop stuff down the guttering and
down the side of the building so it
needs to be accessed to be able to clear
and remove that there's also a fire risk
there're involved if there's a buildup
of waste there um that brings us on to
being able to access our guttering and
any roof repairs from that side because
the location of the bin and cycle
store um could that be replaced to the
center rear of the plans and have
parking Bays instead where the bin and
cycle St
are
um what measures have been put in place
to prevent the business disruption to us
with the number of vehicle movements
that we have during the day and what
assurances or insurance will be provided
by the building contractor in relation
to any impact upon the business be that
physical damage to vehicles or building
access and limitations so we have
between 15 and 20 vehicle movements a
day um we need some construct
Construction materials to be able to um
stop any Dey and dirt on the vehicles
cuz we don't wish to get customer
complaints um we also have 24/7 heavy
industrial use on our site I think it's
really important that although
soundproofing is mentioned it doesn't
address what soundproofing is there and
the bedrooms look onto our site that
will be impacted by noise there's no
mention of soakaway location or if a
cester is going to be installed and
where we've asked that number of times
the building allows a 5 m long car
parking space at the front but the
building on the plans doesn't appear to
be moved back so that means Vehicles
overhang the curb side and cause an
obstruction to pedestrians on the
walkway and also there's only five
parking spaces but it's two bedroom
flats and so that in equality is 10
parking spaces I know I'm out of time
but there was a lot to cover and it
hasn't been addressed in four letters so
thank you very much for your time thank
you I will now hand to the principal
planning officer to outline the
report
uh thank you
chair so this is the application site
outlined in red uh the St Peter's Park
Road um running down up and down the to
the left of the slide here the station
car park to the rear of the site and
this is raring cour is a block of flats
um just the opposite side of the access
into the station car park
so this is an aerial view of the site
the site in question is the one with the
red blob uh theot Center next door which
has been mentioned um sits here the
station car park uh to the rear there
and this is looking onto the site so
we're looking from St Peter's Park Road
so this is the site in
question um again the station car park
can be seen to the rear and this is the
neighboring
garage um so just some photographs of
the site so this is numbers 24 26 and 28
St Peters Park Road and the application
site is to the right here uh another
view of it um so you can see there is a
blank elevation to that property the
joining property here and this is the
application
site um this is the garage that adjoins
the Mt adjoins the application site and
you can see there is an exist in access
to the left hand side which has been
mentioned and again a closer view of the
application building the current
building the application site on the
left and the access to that to the rear
of that site and theot um Center and now
we've walked through the access and
we're looking at the rear of the site
and theot garage that's been referred to
and mentioned is on the right hand side
you can see the back wall um of the
application site there and the planting
you can see behind it is actually on the
embankment to the station car park and
not within the application site and
again that's the other sort of corner of
the application site we've walked
around and you can see again the
planting is as I say out out with the
site but um as a buffer to the station
and the station car park so that's
looking at the side of the application
site um you can see that's Rowan Court
you can see behind there and you can
just see the chimney of the joining
Building 24 26 and 28 St Peter's Park
Road um again this is looking at part of
the rear of the actual application site
as it sits there are and number 24 26
and 28 and you can see there are is some
planting but it's pretty much
self-seeded and not of any particular
Merit on the application site and that
would be lost in the
proposal and then again this is just
looking back through the gate we walked
through so the access to the side so you
can see theot garage is now on the left
and that's the existing building on the
application
site
so Planning Commission is sought for the
erection of a three story building it's
will have two commercial units E-class
uc's E-class and five two bed
flats and this is the proposed site
layout so you can see the two commercial
um property units would sit to the front
of the site there would be um a single a
two-bedroom ground floor flat here in
this location here and with the two
Upper Floor two upper floors to building
excuse me having two Flats each one at
the front and one at the rear but we'll
look at the floor plans in more detail
later so as been mentioned there will be
parking for the commercial units free
car parking spaces
here um there will be the access way
coming round as existing round to a rear
parking area there will be five spaces
as has been mentioned one u space per
flat and it has been considered suitable
to have five spaces due to the very
sustainable location of the application
site so so looking at the building this
is the existing front elevation well
Street Scene so you can see the building
in the middle here is the application
site this is the proposed um
building it would have a height of 10.3
m in total and that would be 1.9 M
taller than this building here so number
2 24 26 and
28 and it would be some 3.9 M taller
than
theot building ad joining it the
materials are would be render red and
yellow bricks and Recon reconed slate
sorry constituted slate and those
materials are common in the A and we do
not raise an objection to those
materials so this is the existing
rightand
elevation and that's the one that faces
currently theot Center and this is a
proposed um elevation the same facing
theot Center again as has been mentioned
there are windows Two Flats um fronting
or facing theot Center they will be um
there is sound proofing and I'll touch
on that and a noise impact assessment
has been carried out and you may have
recalled there is a path that runs for
people to walk and access the rear
parking area and the Garden area from
the proposed layout so the windows here
will be obscure glaze because they do
serve a residential property but there
are windows that also serve that
property to the rear which will let
light and ventilation
in so that's the other elevation facing
on to 24 26 and 28 and again this is the
elevation as proposed it will largely be
a blank elevation there are windows and
it's hard to see but that is a recessed
um part of the building and it really
serves a service core and those windows
will also be obscure glazed there are
balconies here but they are some way
away
from um the flank wall of number 24 26
and 28 and it's not considered there
would be any overlooking or sense of
enclosure or harm from
those and again this is the rear
elevation as we looked at in the photos
of the application side
and this is the proposed um elevation
rear elevation as you can see they're
the balconies we looked at
earlier and we have got some CGI images
of the building so this is looking at
the front so that's the existing
building at 24 26 and 28 this is the
building as you would see it and you can
see the different types of materials
they're
proposing and then this is enough view
of it and we can see the rear view there
as well as proposed under the
cgis so this is existing floor
plan and then we have the proposed
ground floor
plan as has been mentioned so we've got
the two commercial units sitting
here and this is the ground floor flat
here these are the Obscure windows that
were mentioned to prevent people
obviously looking into that flat as they
walk around to access the car parking
area or the bins and cycle storage or
the Garden area and you will note
actually number the ground floor flat
here has its own private Garden again to
provide amenity space but also to ensure
there is no overlooking into those
windows from other uh people
accessing that um so now looking at the
first floor as been mentioned you've got
a flat to the front and a flat to the
rear this is the
recessed um service sort of quarter of
the building so it has though it's a
deep building it does have some
articulation to the front and to the
sides to break it up a bit and the
windows here will be obscured and there
are the kitchen windows here will also
be obscured to prevent any sort of
mutual overlooking between flats and
again the top floor this is the second
floor and it follow is a very similar
pattern to the one below and again you
can see the balconies here and the
distance to the actual edge of the site
and then the building that sits Bey some
2.3 M beyond that so it's not considered
that would be any issues of
um or sense of enclosure overlooking
from those
balconies and that's just the roof plan
of the proposed uh building so this is
the
mot Center here and this is the bin and
cycle storage that has been mentioned so
there will be a a gap between the new
enclosure and of joining oders and it is
um and it's not going to be fixed to the
building um some issues have been raised
um as to maintenance of the building and
some of that does go beyond the scope of
planning and it might be something that
needs to be agreed as part of a party
wall agreement and things like Pest
Control would not be subject to um the
planning consent so not be a material
planning consideration but I do
appreciate there are concerns for the
joining owners and that is why things
like the party wall Agreements are in
place for those sorts of issues to be
resolved and that's just
a the elevations of the bin and cycle
storage just to give you an idea
so just to recap members so this is num
numbers
2428 um sit here and they lie to the
north of the application
site and they are commercial at ground
floor level and residential
above the proposed building as I say is
quite deep and it would project some 9 M
from the rear of that building but there
is the it is um acknowledge that the gap
between the buildings Remains the Same
it is 2.3
M and the windows and doors the near
closest to that are again set in enough
meter or so from that so it is not
considered there would be a sense of
enclosure or overlooking or significant
loss of light to the residential
occupiers of that
property um the proposed Flats
themselves would meet the required
nationally described space standards and
provide light and ventilation for future
occupiers even with some of those build
uh Windows being obscure
glazed um a noise impact assessment has
been
submitted essentially to deal with the
issue of having residential above
commercial but also to to looking being
aware of theot and other commercial
uses in the vicinity and this does uh
ensure that future occupiers would have
a good standard of accommodation and
does ensure that theot Center can
operate and is not adversely affected by
having a sensitive um
neighbor of of residential development
being introduced where there isn't one
currently um environmental health have
agreed the findings of that noise impact
assessment and they rais no objection
subject to safeguarding conditions which
are set out in the
report
um initially concerns were raised by KCC
highways about the about a variety of
Highway issues including the width of
the access road as initially proposed
the size of Park some of the parking
spaces and they also sought
clarification in terms sweat paths where
to ensure Vehicles can enter and exit
the site in forward gear so amended
plans were submitted to and Casey casy
highways are now happy with it and no
raise no objection as has been mentioned
there are three spaces shown here and
they do meet the 5
m um setback so they will be do meet the
standards secured uh expected by KCC
highways and they will be secured for
Comm the commercial units by collapsing
bards so they would be put up when the
commercial units would not be in
operation the access Road will be partly
two ways
so at the widest part here at the
beginning so people there would be no a
need for vehicles to wait on the highway
they could pull in even if something was
um turning out and then it does narrow
down to a single width as you move into
the site but that width is the same site
as a current Access Road the the
narrower width the single whip
so and as as has been seen it is a
current to access road which has been
used by vehicles but admittedly not that
recently um it as has been mentioned
there is one space only for each of the
flats but again it is considered
sustainable location there are shops and
Facilities around and obviously we have
the
station um in nearby as well and it has
been demonstrated by sweat paths as I
say that Vehicles can come and
enter um in forward gear so it's not
considered there would be an
issue in terms of Highway Safety or
parking and there is parking available
on street and in the in the surrounding
area as well as if um more parking was
required uh as the flats are two bed
units there is a requirement for amenity
space to be provided and this is
provided as you can see here in two ways
so you have the private amenity space
that we talked about to serve the ground
floor
flat but also a communal a space here it
is notice that the communal space is
relatively
small um but it would effectively allow
for clothes drying and some amenity
space and sitting out space to serve the
occupiers of the flats and it has
um it's a balance of creating the
adequate parking and Service uh
servicing facilities for the flats and
the commercial
units and
also
providing um dwellings to add to the
housing stock of uh this District as
well and in this case we have the
undertaking for the required Sam
contribution so the officer
recommendation is for approval thank you
chair thank you I move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
could I have have a second for that
please councelor matterface thank
you and uh I have councelor Garner has
already requested to speak thank
you thank you very thank you very much
yeah I mean I'm I am very familiar with
this site it's just up the road from me
um and I called it in because I I have I
share a number of the concerns that were
raised earlier and I don't I familiar
with it because there was a plan
application here that was refused right
the beginning of the year for a number
of reasons that I was hoping that would
have all been fully overcome and I don't
believe I can satisfactory say that they
have been so if I just run through the
reasons that the previous one was
refused the first one was cuz I think it
was one story higher the previous
application so it was refused because of
height depth design and all the rest of
it um no so
a um a floor has been removed but it's
still I think it's still as high because
it's still going up v-shaped at the
top um but that that could be
questionable I
suppose the adverse impact on the
highway is one that I'm really have a
concern about obviously I can see and
I've heard KC highways seem to have um
changed their opinion um through the
course of this I mean I almost I find
that one of the things I find
incredible is this two-way access that's
been acceptable is the length of a car
it's no more than the length of a car so
it's basically a car being able to pull
in just about over the pavement and wait
for anything coming out the other out
the other way and I I I don't believe
that personally I don't believe that's
acceptable I don't believe that equals
two-way access onto the site it equals a
car being able to pull into a space and
weight and I couldn't quite make out
there where the pathway how wide the
pathway is for
residents um to go up when they get out
of their flat um because they want to go
and use the
communal play Space doorstep play Space
which is bed against the side there
which was one of the other reasons why
the the previous application was refused
because there was a lack of communal
doorstep Place space well if you live in
the bottom flat you've got a couple of
meters to yourself there but if you live
in one of the other four flats you
you've got
to you've got to um wait maybe in the
two-way place for that it to be safe to
walk up there then that see seems a
totally inadequate space for all the
residents to use um especially if
they're all hanging there washing out in
there there's not going to be a great
deal of space to play in and I know
being right next to the railway car park
is not going to be the most Pleasant
place to go and sit or play in um so I'm
I I'm I mean obviously I'm looking
forward to hearing what other people
have got to say but at the moment it
doesn't seem particularly particularly
accept able to me and I will also add um
from what we heard earlier as well those
three cars out the front I don't care
what anybody else says I walk past her
every day that space is not big enough
that I saw a fiesta type car there just
this morning as I was walking out and
that was just about not hanging over
onto the pavement and you you get an
estate in there it will be hanging into
the pavement over the pavement um it it
just is isn't acceptable and I can't see
I assume any any delivery vehicles that
are going to come to one of those two um
two retail units are going to turn up
when when there aren't any customers
there parked on that space they
certainly can't come after it shut
because the ballards will be up stopping
any anyone else using it um and I will
just pick up one of the points that was
raised earlier by uh the lady from the
garage next door there was a concern
about um about protection to the side of
their their building because there were
flammable materials kept um on that side
of the of their building
um and especially as it's a car parking
space um is is there going to be any
protections put up against that side but
at the moment unless I'm looking to be
persuaded otherwise I can't see that
this is a good enough Improvement on the
one that you refused at the beginning of
the year thank
you thank you chair I just wanted to
come back on one of the points about the
parking at the front of the site that
that that's that's of concern there is
obviously you've seen from the photos
that the parking spaces there are
existing parking spaces so this proposal
doesn't make it any worse in terms of
effectively thinking of of what the
impact of the development is it doesn't
worse than the existing situation with
regards that those parking spaces now
they have been obviously measured in the
sense of the plans in terms of what the
new building where the new building goes
to give that 5 meter depth and to your
point about the previous
application and what that actually um
what that actually had the parking
spaces at the rear for example were 4.8
M depth and that isn't actually adequate
when it comes to kcc's parking stands in
terms of the space that they've got um
just in terms of the point about um cars
turning in and that sort of two-way
element um I understand what your the
point about the the the ability to turn
in and then be able to adapt in terms of
how you've turned in if there is a car
coming the other way um the issue with
the conflict on the layout as it is is
that occasions where that actually will
happen because of the number of spaces
to the rear you've only got five spaces
at the rear um it is it is minimal in
terms of the potential for that conflict
to exist and I think if if we were
looking at lots of cast parking space at
the rear of a larger residential
development then I think that there
would be more justification to suggest
you need much more space for that twocc
car passing thing because there are
going to be more occasions where there's
going to be that conflict uh but
obviously they have made provision in
this instance there is an existing route
there obviously it's not used in the
same way there's a gate but there is a
access to the yard at the rear at the
moment the site obviously was filled
with vehicles but it's now being cleared
so again that's an existing vehicle
access that goes down the side and again
even though there's additional movements
clearly to the rear it's that point
about whether or there's enough conflict
to justify um there being harm the one
other thing sorry just add adding on a
few things one thing that has been
mentioned is about those about the bards
that you can see on this plan you've
seen there um so at the moment there is
no condition requiring details of those
ballards to be provided to the local
authority of our condition because
normally we would put a landscaping
condition on which would give the
technical details of what's going on but
actually that has all been provided
through the application for the hard
surfacing where the fences are and all
that sort of things so if members felt
that it was necessary for a level of
control over what the design of those
ballads are um then that is something
that could be conditioned and a
condition could be added to any approval
to require those details prior to the
use or occupation of of the building
thank you
CH thank you can I just just come back
cuz thank you thank you for that that
update and I can see how I mean I can
see how in an Ideal World this that
would work if each of the flat occupiers
understood um that they have one car
parking space between them and that
every time they have someone coming to
visit they will tell them before they
come you can't park on site you can't
come up and down a but that that isn't
going to happen there will be cars
coming up so there is is a need for
better access and it just doesn't weigh
up to me that where this was refused
previously because it was single track
access it now is okay to be this extra 5
m and I know cuz I do know the area I
know what will happen is that although
visitors could go and pass Park in the
car park around the back especially on a
Saturday when it's free they won't
though they'll all go down Percy Road
opposite which people do already at the
moment and if there's one thing that
people down Percy Road stop and tell me
every time I walk down there is what are
you going to do about the parking down
this road and I've said well we're going
to put another few Flats there so that
more people can come and park down there
if I was fores but I'm
not can I'm going to I'm going to bring
back the planning applications manager
to answer some of your points so sorry I
I I misspoke when I previously was
talking because there is there is a
condition which is condition 19 which
requires details prior to the occupation
of all including of all walls fences or
other means of enclosure proposed so we
will get details off the Ballard so
sorry just to conf no condition needs to
be added it it's already on uh the
recommendation I think just to I think
it might be useful with reference that's
been made the previous refusal that that
we show you the previous refusal um so
if you bear with me one second I'm just
going to take control of the screen and
just
show so in terms of the the previous
application so this was this was for the
commercial units and seven Flats so it's
now five flats um and you can see at the
rear um where there is um it was
considered that there Not only was it an
issue in terms of the parking spaces as
I mentioned they're not they don't
actually Accord with highest standards
there wasn't enough room for cars to
turn around at the rear uh and if I go
back sorry I have to do this on other
screen
um to the actual
proposed you can see obviously the way
that it's change in terms of the number
of parking spaces comes down so again I
appreciate what you're saying about
there's still potential for vehicular
conflict but there's less potential with
the previous proposal and obviously
there is now a turning area which
highways have agreed allows for the 6x6
to turn around there I mean the main
thing which you know everyone is in
agreement that we are trying to ensure
that vehicles are exiting in a forward
gear because everyone knows what some
pet par roads like therefore we need to
make sure that's the case and again this
is the balance that's been made in terms
of the previous application was
obviously the reduction in units the
change in design but Al the Improvement
of the access to the rear we are in a
location where um we do expect people to
have cars although it is Edge of Center
very close to the town center it is
sustainable and therefore we think this
is the balance that you get by getting
cars on site uh and developing the site
um so therefore it's it's sort of the
tradeoff here is to get you know get as
much safe car parking as you can on site
and that's you know that's what we've
put it Forward on that
basis thank you go to councelor Alban
next
please I thought councelor bford was in
front of me chair but doesn't you pretty
much together so okay thank you
um yeah I'm not going to go over what
council Garner said he's made clear what
his things so I'm not going to repeat
those uh chair the only well I'll tell a
lie the only one I would repeat is I am
really concerned about where the uh at
the mot Center where they are uh the
gases and uh
are stored and you can't expect them to
move the G their storage because they
want to build build this so I think
there there has to be some kind of
mitigation there if if it is approved uh
that that is
protected um what I what I wanted to ask
uh that the the two commercial
units it doesn't actually say within
there is what their use classes are so I
I think that's
important uh as to I suppose the
question is why why haven't we got a uh
a firm uh comment from the developer as
to what these will be used as or is it
that obviously then that they would have
to make a separate application for the
uses so in other words the development
is building the unit
and and is controlled under this consent
if it's granted but the use of those are
not so um you know reading the condition
especially uh in relation so if there is
a they come in and they want uh food
units takeaways or whatever so that will
obviously increase traffic that will
increase everything there so I think
that is a concern that that I have chair
um and I just wonder if the officers
could uh could answer that thank
you uh the class E use Class E so that
does cover a number of
different things
they so it could be for example retail
it could be a cafe it could be a number
of things that are covered by use Class
E chair can I come back just so can I
just confirmed it may be me that I've
missed it in the
conditions um but could you point out
where it says that in the in the
conditions
sorry thank you in that case it's
Council Baer
please thank you chair um well I I think
this is less dominant than the previous
application and and actually I think
it's very well designed to accommodate
um both commercial units and five very
much needed Flats um efforts have been
made to make the living viable with
Amity Amun spaces there have been
improvements to the parking provision
but this is an issue everywhere
especially in our towns um I think I
would like to to support this
application subject to some of the
conditions raised by our speaker tonight
thank you
thank you and I had councilor mat face
thank you chair Su of what I was going
to say has already been said on the
Assumption the outline of the building
is as the existing former computer
repair place I know perfectly well like
Council Garo that you can walk along
there could walk along there when it was
an operation and vehicles were
overhanging the pavement and that is a
concern um St Peter's Park Road is very
difficult to park in there double yellow
lines a lot of businesses there and I
have concerns that two commercial units
with only three parking spaces depending
what they are um I just don't think it's
sufficient and I am concerned also with
the five spaces at the rear which I know
they've reduced the number and
everything but where are all the other
people going to park because as Council
Garner said Percy Road wormsley Road
Edith Road are always very heavily
parked up and um I've just a visions of
more sort of conflict there but that's
the only thing the other points have
been
covered thank you chair just just to
come back on the the highways points I
understand members are concerned about a
combination of the the commercial and
also the um the parking at the rear I
mean in terms of the commercial that's
being
created um obviously there is a a large
commercial unit there that obviously
generates vehicle movements at the
moment in terms of the parking for that
that that unit obviously you've got um
spaces at the front that's obviously
being
replicated just as a number of
businesses along there parking at the
front um if a car is is driving along
there and there are no spaces at the
front in terms of the business aspect
they won't Park in they won't you know
they they wouldn't be anywhere to park
for them so again that's not necessarily
I think a point of conflict from from
our perspective
um in terms of parking provision at the
rear and the
arrangement the in terms of thinking
about highways and their comments
specifically their comments are
specifically referencing the fact that
it is in a location as I mentioned
earlier that is walkable to everything
um this is something therefore that we
have to be mindful of in terms of any
potential refusal on insufficient
parking or inadequate and unsafe because
again highways haven't objected on a
safety ground in terms of that work
working relationship with the access
that's there at the moment and the
parking at the rear and maneuvering
around um so again it is about a balance
being struck here whether or not you are
trying to provide the parking or not
because we are in a location where I I
think there is a there would be a strong
argument if there was no parking
whatsoever uh that an applicant could
put forward um it's not in the town
center but it is you know it's it's well
served by a number of of things we do
feel this is the the correct balance I
just wanted to touch on one point
because of what counil aord has said
about the the the sort of the what's
been mentioned so just to confirm
obviously the ballards and the details
of the ballards in terms of where they
are they've obviously been specifically
put there is something that is going to
be subject condition to ensure that they
are installed um you know prior to the
use of of that building just to pick up
one of the points that that Annabel has
also mentioned about the recommendations
of the noise impact assessment so some
of those recommendations include the
fact that you've got double glazed
Windows to living rooms and bedrooms um
but rather than um normal glazing it's
thickened glazing so at the moment if
you're looking at a normal single glaze
window you're looking at about 3 mm
depth you're looking at 6 mm depth for
the first pane a gap and then 4 mm depth
so there are a number of requirements
it's not a standard build to ensure that
there is mitigate you know there is
clear mitigation in terms of that
relationship with the neighboring
property and anabel's obviously already
mentioned about the what's what's
potentially covered by other legislation
be it party W act or indeed if there are
issues with you know peson that is
something that Environmental Protection
would look at um and so is my final
point there is a construction management
plan condition one of the requirements
of that is to look at dust control
measures and that is obviously something
that's been made mentioned as part of it
so not only is that covered by parts of
the Environmental Protection act
generally in terms of human health dust
control measure me measures in this
instance could obviously help to
mitigate any impact from construction in
terms of you know not just one business
on one side but just generally in the
area thank you I've got councilor Wing
next please I'm not going to mention
anything that's been mentioned before
but I just like to maybe some
clarification about party allall
agreement is the bin and waste store
clearly it can't be attached to a a
metal clad building so is there a gap
between there and if there is a gap
between between uh I thought Party wall
agreement was to do with when you're
actually trying to do something to your
neighbor's wall and if there's a gap
does the does can party wall agreement
then be used to try and deal with that
Gap and the other thing that worries me
is uh there's a bin store so I mean
there you've got uh I'm I'm assuming
there'll be one bin per
household they'll be they'll be dragged
out uh they'll be dragged out once a
week and put on the highway somewhere or
on the on the you know to be emptied are
we not then filling the the the two-way
passing Gap and possibly the Shop's
parking store and possibly the pavement
with bins that are required to be
brought forward onto the highway for our
our our great waste teams to to empty
them so is there not another Hazard down
the line
there
so just to come back on the the first
point with regards to you know potential
you're right in the sense of that it ter
of physical alterations to something
that either abuts or is in fact um
connected to is usually what the party
War work covers in this instance there
is a gap so this is the the the drawing
that shows there there is a gap because
as you say it's actually attaching to it
is is arguably a bit more of a problem
because it's very difficult to do that
um The annotation here in IND indicates
and I think it's on the elevation as
well um it's not on this elevation but
there is a there's a a panel that's
that's put at the rear basically on this
annotation that would basically extend
up to the boundary but a but it to try
and basically minimize the potential for
things such as you know animals or
things to go down there I think with
regards to how that would be dealt with
it as Annabel said earlier it's not it's
not a m it's not a planning
consideration that we would look at in
terms of the design of buildings um it's
it's something that can happen I mean I
think you know everyone may have had
experiences with with pests such as rats
or mice but that is something that then
would looked at Again by other
legislation obious we want to create a
situation where we are um resulting in
something happening but that isn't the
case here the main thing is that it's
set away the point about maintenance is
something that would be subject to the
the relationship between the landowner
in this inst and the management company
with regards to that area at the rear
and the neighboring property um and so
it's not something that we can mandate
through the planning uh planning
conditions your point about bin storage
is something that has been looked at um
because um the waste and recycling team
have commented on it and this is where
the actual width of the access is key
because the width of that access is is
3.7 M um which basically allows for a
vehicle to very comfortably pass down it
and there is a section of land as well
that indicates that there is a strip
where bins would be collected on the day
of collection which wasted recycling
team have agreed because they have a
carry distance that they obviously would
walk from the highway to collect and go
back so it's too far for them to go to
actually the bin storage at the RIS they
do need to be moved closer now you know
I appreciate that we are then relying on
people putting in the right place but
that is no different from just a normal
householder putting the bin in the right
place and for it to be collected and
that's something the Wast and recycling
team would effectively pick up and
obviously if bins aren't presented where
they can collect them they won't collect
them and they're justified in not doing
that so um we do feel like again this is
the this is a a balance that allows for
bins to be stored at the rear rather
than have a bin store that's on the
front of the property which I know that
waste recycling colleagues would prefer
we had but for a design reason we do
usually look to rate at the rear with
then a collection area first of all we
further close to the the road we do
think that there is enough maneuver
ability to get car still down there
without having that blocked basically by
bins being stored
there councel Kean thank you
um is this echoing it sounds
ech right thank you um I mean having
listened to it all I'm not sure there's
planning reasons for
refusal um I think there's a number of
points in the design that are
disappointing and in in particular can
you just tell me I know it's not well I
don't believe that there's a a sort of
minimum play spacing but what size is
that communal play space cuz it looks
really really tiny to me and as I say I
I appreciate that's still not a planning
refusal reason but I would be
curious and
a um so yeah um just get Annabel to
um she's just measuring it I think the
width the width is it it looks from from
I it's oh S I need to get the scale roll
out of my bag so
um good questions like this make them
work oh that's actually sign on it I
can't read it oh it's 32 square m but
what's the what's the scan on there I
think it's one for
100 it looks about 2 m wide does
um so just to confirm in terms of the
the the width at the the the sorry oh
it's I'm not on the
M the width to the um to the biggest
Point yeah here on the plan is is is
basically about 2.3 M wide
uh the depth though is obviously quite
long in terms of being 13 so you're
looking at about it's got down on the
plan it's about 32 square meters to your
point counc Ken you're absolutely right
there is no minimum standard um and and
then this is uh I appreciate you've
heard officer say this a few times the
balance here is to get the parking and
we have this in town centers we have
this in areas just outside Town centers
you know we are trying to get that
balance um and sometimes you can't
achieve everything but we do feel like
this is enough space to have closed
driving facilities having a close line
um to you know to support the the flats
above again one of the issues that c
Garner mentioned this earlier with the
previous application is that you didn't
have any play Bas or any doorstop play
space and it was seven Flats so again
you've got five here one of which does
have it space at the rear and it's those
four flats that are above that that that
do have this this narrow space
face councelor matterface just a very
quick point if you go in the railway
station car park over the little Bridge
you're in the Memorial Park uh which has
quite a lot of play space but um that's
you know
that's
just and can I just check um the bin
collection point will that be clearly
marked so that people know that that is
where they've got to put their bins
and I hate to come back to this but I am
concerned that the bin storage area next
to a point where the neighbors are
saying Pest Control is a problem I know
that was said just now that it's not um
a material planning consideration around
the pest control and the party wall
agreements but if that is likely to
cause a problem for the residents here
with their bin storage in that area
would that be something that that we
would need need to
consider um so to the first point the
Landscaping condition covers the hard
surfacing so in terms of the plan that
you can see on here um it you know it
can be looked at in terms of denoting on
the ground a change in in surface
material as part of the Landscaping
condition um in terms of the point about
where the bin storage is um there's
nothing inherent in bin storage you know
you know in terms of where it is on on a
site if there you know if the that would
necessarily result in a direct
impact you know that that would be
justified or significant enough to
refuse an application with regard
regards to resulting in pests um it's I
must admit it's something that I haven't
come across as a as a suggestion frankly
that would that would warrant uh you
know a refus of an application because
obviously there are bin stor storages
and and in this instance it is enclosed
you know it's is in an enclosure um so
and again there are measures under the
Environmental protection act and the
Environmental Protection Team look at
with regards to pest issues so it's not
something that would result in a you
know an impact from this development to
Warrant refusal in our
view councelor alurn yeah very very
quickly chair um having listened to
everything I'm mindful that I think on
balance that uh I would vote to approve
it but I that would need to be subject
to the protection of the the gases area
of
theot sentor and I'd like that as a a
condition if that's at all
possible so from the from the discussion
earlier obviously the the purpose as far
as I understand it of why those Bol ODS
have been placed there relate to that uh
as far as I understand it from the
submission taking account of the
comments that were made during the
course of the application and and
previous application so that's why the
ballards are going to be subject to that
Landscaping condition and again the
importance here is that actually they're
not just a metal post you know that we
actually are looking at something that
more substantial that offers that
protection so that is something that
obviously we can feed back in the
condition submission with the with the
conditions officer to make that
clear okay I don't have any other
speakers so we will now put the motion
for the officer's recommendation for
approval to the vote those in
favor
and those
against any
extensions thank you that is
carried the next item on the agenda is
um item 5 C land adjacent to 198 monton
Street mon
monton uh for public speaking in favor
of the application I have Miss Annabelle
gurlak you have three minutes thank you
chair um I'm Anabel GAC I'm actually the
resident of 198 mon Street and developer
of 198a mon Street um firstly I want to
reiterate that all tools are down and
nothing has gone forward since the
summer until this matter is resolved um
secondly I want to bring to light that
um there are no conditions attached to
the planning permission that could not
go through permitted development for the
Loft and the single
extension um also I'd like to bring to
attention the council um scheme was
utilized for this build as well um plans
provided to me by the architect were
simply built um and I was given the go
ahead by them um the vux window at the
top of the property is very acute um and
thus wouldn't um have an intrusion to
any neighbors or land adjacent or to the
rear of the property um and the rear of
the property is farmland and Woodland um
uh the access to the back of my property
and that is uh the utilities pathway has
been gridlocked so that is very dormant
land and has actually overgrown to the
degree that I've actually had to
maintain it myself because it's
excessive and it comes over The Back
Fence of both of the properties so there
there's nobody there that could you know
be intrusion upon at all by the Dorma um
I'd also like to bring to attention in
mon Street there are many door windows
um too um spaces parking spaces there is
ample parking spaces on the front of the
property um and um also I'm I'm eager to
get going on this property and just get
the front cleared up uh for the local
residents um so I I would like to get
this moving as quick as possible it's
been you know some time been delayed and
tools have been down so I I'd really
appreciate your consideration for this
to be warranted please thank
you thank you um speaking under Council
rule 20.1 councelor
bambridge um Smith first okay councelor
Smith instead thank you thank you um
thank you chair um and thank you thank
you for hearing us on this um I've been
approached by uh monton Parish Council
um and they apologize that they are
unable to be here this evening due to
prior commitments had they been um they
would wish to make members aware of the
following that um the parish council has
always oppos development on this site
based on
overdevelopment impact on neighboring
properties and lack of adequate offre
street parking provision um over recent
years three applications have been
submitted to this site each
progressively larger the first was for a
two-bedroom property then a
three-bedroom property and now five bed
property clearly the plot size is not
increased so the development has become
increasingly cramped and
imposing the parish has two major
concerns with current application o
overdevelopment and parking I'll speak
to over
development um this is an extremely
narrow plot to increase the size of the
house in three to five bedrooms a
substantial rear extension has been
added and has been added um rather than
is proposed to be added um together with
development of the roof space this puts
the development out of
kilter uh with adjacent properties
leaving it with minimal separation a
very small rear garden and no front
garden at all in the report officers
State the proposals will not
significantly alter the
footprint whereas a rough estimate of
the plans
and uh shows that they actually increase
the footprint by at least one
thir the parish council consider this to
be very significant alteration to the
footprint highlighting concerns
regarding overdevelopment and the
resulting impact including including
overlooking of the neighboring
properties um and specifically the
parish mentions that it um will Overlook
200a or does overlook
200a
um my uh sense is
that and and without being able to see
the um the rear of the property um my
sense is that it
is overbearing outer scale and out of
kilter um with the rather modest
Bungalows which typify the village of
monton um and um I will leave it to
councilor Banbridge to talk about
parking but I would say that okay in
that case I'm going to leave it to
Council of bambridge to talk about
parking thank you thank you chair I've
got the mic microphone now okay so so um
yes mson um sorry mson Parish council's
um been very concerned about this um the
Kent design guide States properties the
four plus bedroom should be allocated
three parking spaces in a rural location
um this is a rural location yet only two
off street parking spaces um are
provided in the plans um the guide does
suggest these requirements can be
mitigated where sustainable travel links
are evident but monton does not have
sustainable tra travel links there's
very infrequent bus service main for
school runs and nothing at all in the
evenings and that's it so Monon is very
dependent on cars and um in this rural
community there's been an emergence of
um four and five-bedroom new builds in
the village in the last few years and as
a result mon has experienced a huge
increase in um traffic congestion so
it's important to adhere to these these
rules around parking spaces um any sort
of on street parking resulting from this
development will impact on a very narrow
section of monton Street we'll also
compromise the award Jun function with
Middle Lane directly opposite the site
um the applicant has permission for a
three-bedroom property um we feel
anything larger than this will result in
an unacceptable impact on neighboring
properties and will cause an overspill
of parked cars in a narrow Lane wholly
unsuited for further parking and so we
would ask that this amended application
is refused on the reasons um stated by
councelor Abby Smith and
myself thank you
thank you I will now hand to the
principal planning officer to outline
the
report thank you chair so again this is
the application site outlined in red we
have blue land here 198 which is landing
the same ownership as the application
site and this is monton Street um
running across the slide here and that
is Miller's Lane running up there
so this is an aial view of the site so
we can see Miller's Lane and this is the
application site
here and members will be aware and it's
been raised again that planning consent
was granted in 2021 for the erection of
free bed twoot twostory dwelling on the
site and this application seeks to vary
condition two of that consent which was
the approved plan conditions to allow
the erection of a single story rear
extension a rear Doral
window and essentially to create a
five-bedroom dwelling so and the
application as has been mentioned is
part retrospective it's
substantially a substantial amount of
work has been undertaken but it's not
complete so this is the front of the
property with the dwelling as you can
see as I say already part
constructed this is the rear of the site
uh with this is 200 U mon Street to the
left uh you as you can see it's a
two-story dwelling number 200 and it has
a rear extension single story here and
you can see um we're looking at the
application site here that it is under
construction and the Dormer is partly
taking
shape um there and this is looking
from the garden essentially of
198 um so again you can see the Dorma
and it's being built out and you can see
there is a small
um addition here to 198 with a window
set there so this I'm going to do a lot
of comparison between this application
before us and the previous one so
members can get a feel as to what has
changed so this is a block plan that was
approved in uh
2021 so as you can see the dwelling here
parking to the front and a garden area
to the
rear so if you this is the block pan for
the proposed dwelling that we're
considering tonight so again it has a
similar format the dwelling um this is
the extension that's been mentioned here
this is the original house uh the house
is approved in 2021 and again there were
you're parking to the front and a garden
area to the
rear so this is the front as approved in
2021 uh the front elevation that we're
now looking
at uh this is the rear elevation as
approved in
2021 and this is where the and this is
the proposed um rear elevation so this
is where the main changes are going to
to obviously are taking place so the
rear single story extension is flat
roofed as you can see here with a
lantern it runs the width of the
dwelling and has a depth of 4 M and it
increases the depth of the dwelling to
15.8
M so this is the side
elevation sorry that's sorry go back to
that one I haven't told you about the
Dorma the re overall height of the
dwelling would remain the same so that's
8.3 M but the eaves height would
increase from 4.7 M to 5
m the dormal would be set down from the
ridge by 0.2
M and in from the edge of the roof by
0.15 and 0.2
M um and the rear sorry the extension
would actually have a height of 3 3
meters and 3.7 if you include the
Lantern and given the location of the
Dormer and the extension to the rear and
the fact they are flanked by other
dwellings it's they're not highly
visible from public V Vantage points so
and as such is considered there would
not be any adverse impact from approving
them on the C appearance of the
area so that's the side elevation as
approved in 2021 that faced 198 mon
Street and this is it um before us now
so you can see the Dormer here and the
additional
extension here um this is the other side
elevation so facing on to uh number 200
um as approved
in excuse me
2021 and this is what we're now
considering so the extension here with
the Lantern and the Dormer here
and so looking at the floor plans this
is uh it was twostory as approved in
2021 and this is what's um now before us
for consideration
so we now have the free stories
essentially so You' and this is the
extension that's being
proposed and this third uh floor would
be created by means of that door
facilitating um additional floor
space uh there so the proposed ding
would be served by two off Street um
parking spaces to the front and it would
also have a private uh rear
Garden as has been mentioned in the
previous item there are no um space
standards for garden sizes and it still
would have a usable Garden space for
ameni sitting out closed drying Etc our
doorstep play
Space um mention has been made about
concerns that it should be served by
more than two parking spaces there is
only room on site for two parking spaces
but there is parking available along
monton Street and so it is considered
that it is
acceptable to have two parking spaces in
this
instance in terms of the living
conditions of adjoining occupiers it is
notice well whilst the overall height of
the dwelling would not change the form
of the roof does change to accommodate
the
Dormer um but is not considered to be
significantly harmful to the residential
amenities of adjoining occupiers um the
Dormer windows the windows in the Dormer
itself would look out over the rear
garden and then onto Countryside as has
been mentioned and is not considered
that they would be any worse than the
the rear windows in the first floor that
have already been
approved um it's not considered there
would be any loss of light or sense of
enclosure from the proposed
development um es especially given that
the rear elevation is self facing and
the actual position of the dwelling
within the site does not change so the
officer recommendation is for
approval
thank I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted could I have a
second for that
please councelor
driver and I've got one hand I've
already had up for speaking councelor
alurn yeah thank you chair
um I can see nothing wrong with this at
all um I'll go along with the officer
recommendation for uh
approval um I think what needs to be
taken into account that should they have
built it as it was F firstly approved uh
that probably the rear extension would
be permitted development The Loft
conversion would be permitted
development and the Dorma rear Dorma
window would be permitted development so
uh they they could have done this
without any consent whatsoever after the
building was built so I can see no
reason to refuse it chair thank you very
much could I ask Mr Livingstone to just
come back and confirm that what you have
said is true no D I know I know but I
just want I want him on record as
saying um so yeah rear do windows it's a
it's a cubic content issue in terms of
whether or not it's permitted it's a
detached property so they got 50 square
meters to work with um so it you know it
doesn't go any higher than there's a
there's a gap of uh more than 20 cm from
the EES to the start of the Dormer so
yeah that looks like it would be
permitted development obviously it's
tile hung um sorry it's not been tile
hung yet but it will be tile hung and
obviously that's the bit that has to
match in terms of similar appearance in
terms of the rear extension again it's a
detached property so that allows you to
go out the 4 met in depth it's 2.6 m to
the eaves so it is a you know it is um
you know it's it's a it's not at a
height of 3 m which if it was 3 m within
2 met of the boundary then they've got a
bit more of an issue it's not PD so uh
from from looking at the plans this
evening I would say this those two
developments are would be ited if they
were and obviously the situation has
presented itself because it's simply
been constructed at the same time as the
dwelling was
constructed do I have any other
questions or comments coun councilor
Garner yeah I'd just like to I mean as
you know I take a keen interest in what
Kent highways say about um planning
applications so I've had a look at the
Kent Kent
highways the latest of two
of submissions there on there it they
say that they uh confirm that provided
the following requirements are secured
by condition or planning obligation then
I raise no objection and there are two
well there are more than two there a
couple of things that I've noticed they
asking for the submission of a
construction management Plan before the
commencement of any
development um and I can't see it on
this one was there one on the the one
that's already got planning
permission and cuz I couldn't see that
uh and the location of the telegraph
pole removal position we haven't heard
anything about that in the report or
anything I just wondered if you could
put my mind at rest about the telegraph
poll um the construction management plan
was attached to the condition was
attached to the original application and
they did submit that and it was approved
and obviously works have commenced so
we've not SE sort to reapply
that um sorry I've lost the off one
there uh yeah the telegraph pole has
already been remove uh moved to allow um
access to the front to allow for parking
so if I go back to the
photograph you can just see on the edge
of the photograph in this location here
previously it was pretty much in the
middle of the application site so it's
already been remove uh removed so we
have not reimposed
that uh
condition so it that's great thank you
very much so that does sort of make me
wonder maybe doesn't impact this
application but you know KCC highways
sent in that submission on the 23rd of
November which is only a couple of weeks
ago asking for a couple of things that
have already been delivered I mean do
they do they not realize that these
things have been done before they before
they do it it's so one of the things
that makes me worry about what KCC
highways actually say to
us um I I appre I understand what you
say that the paragraph at the start of
the the highway comment talks about you
know it may have been relocated in terms
of the telegraph poll specifically
obviously in this instance the
assessment's been done on the basis of
the plans I wouldn't expect casc to need
to visit the site to to actually give a
consultation comment so that's why he's
that you they've asked for the
re-imposition uh I must admit I kind of
agree with the construction management
plan point but again um it's KCC would
not have appreciated necessarily that
the works actually have got to the stage
that they have uh hence they've
recommended it so I'm I'm not trying to
defend KCC necessarily but just to give
some context around
[Music]
it coun Matas did you want to we assume
the applicant had to pay to have that
move must have been pretty
expensive yes okay it doesn't look like
I've got any more comments and we'll now
put the motion for the office's
recommendation for approval to the vote
those in
favor
and were there any others abstentions or
against no in that case that is carried
now members uh we have one more item on
the um agenda for tonight and then the
reserve list does anyone want to for a
five minute Comfort break as it is now
10 to 9 yeah we are going to take a five
minute Comfort break thank you it
doesn't matter who says it councilor
Albin I take no notice of
you
for
e
right I think we're all back now so um
we're going to start go on with um item
5 g vattenfall land at Port of Ramsgate
Royal Harbor approach in Ramsgate I have
speaking in favor of the application Mr
Doug Molton you have three minutes good
evening members the proposed platform is
a simple structure measuring 11.5 by 22
m to the south of the existing vat andf
offices the development is fully
compliant with local plan policy sp1
which supports Port related development
the port of Ramsgate is a major economic
driver in the locality with offshore
wind being a vital component the council
recognizes the importance of the port
with leveling up funding sought to
invest and so create a green Port
including the support of the renewable
energy sector the applicant operates 10
offshore Wind forms offshore wind is
critical component of the country's
Energy Mix and in delivering 0 2050
accordingly the maintenance of the
existing wind turbines is key to
maximizing renewable energy generation
the boat platform is required to
facilitate the efficient operation and
maintenance of the kentish flats ksh
Flats extension and thit offshore wind
farms with a total capacity of 440 megaw
currently vat envel sends vessels across
from the marina to the linkspan and then
offshore and London array use a a
pontoon located about 200 M Southwest of
their yard c not a practical or
efficient setup the facility will be in
joint use with London array so the
structure has maximum operational
benefit the development will be
installed at a fixed height matching the
level of the adjacent dock the only part
of the development that be visible is
the hydraulic cranes with cranes already
present within the harbor the
development already benefits from a
marine management license granted in
March
2022 there was no statut objections to
the application with no objection from E
either Ramsgate Town Council or the
Heritage and design Forum with no
letters of objections from any local
residents the construction of the
platform is short being only Circa 7even
weeks using a modular build and will
take place between April and September
so outside of overwintering birds the
construction methodology of the platform
is clearly set out in a detailed
construction Environmental Management
plan which is correctly referenced in
the draft conditions the document this
document alongside the Shadow habitats
regulation statement has been agreed by
both Natural England and the council
ecologist as appropriate to mitigate any
limited potential environmental impacts
specifically around Birds within the
harbor a highway technical note was
submitted in support of the application
which demonstrates there is sufficient
car parking available at the existing
office the development will not be a
generator of new vehicle trips but more
but what will allow the bet the
workforce a better facility which can be
more easily and efficiently board Bo and
then with the necessary equipment to
facilitate the offshore wind farms it is
considered that the proposed fixed booat
Landing platform fully Accords with the
local plan constitutes sustainable
development and we respectfully request
that councilors support the officer
recommendation and approve the planning
application thank
you thank you the planning applications
manager will now outline the
report thank you chair um so the
application is for a landing platform
for vessel connected with the operation
of uh the wind farms by vat Force so
we're looking at the Port of
Ramsgate um The Landing platform will be
in the location that previously had uh
pontoons which were end of life and have
been removed subsequently so if we look
at the next image you'll see uh an
aerial view of of where this platform
would
be um so the main planning
considerations are the principal
development the impact on the character
appearance of the area and the impact on
the environment um as mentioned
obviously there was a previous ponon
that was used for these facilities um
the new platform uh would be um
constructed via 15 uh steel uh tubular
columns which will be piled into the the
the the har floor the platform itself is
11 me 112 M by uh 22 M you have um the
cranes that the applicant has mentioned
um in two locations um
across the um across the platform you've
also got access ladders at three points
down the platform as well um but the
actual level of the platform is at the
same level of the the dock so in terms
of the principle of development it's
acceptable against policy sp1 um it's
you know it is a port related need uh
and therefore it's supported by that
principal policy there's no impact on
the character appearance of the area
it's enti High L appropriate to have
this type of development in this area
visually um in terms of the impact on
the environment the applicant did do uh
prea with us uh and we advised um on the
previous experience that we'd had with
regards to other developments in the
port uh and so a construction management
plan has been submitted as referenced
which includes particular measures to
mitigate the impact of construction on
bird species linked to the designated
sites in the area so again as mentioned
there's a condition which requires that
that no pring Works can occur between
September and March uh the use of of
soft start piling to minimize
disturbance when it does occur uh a
pre-commencement bird survey to occur
and also a Marine Mammal Observer to be
present uh KCC biodiversity have agreed
with the measures as well as uh Natural
England in agreeing the shadow habitat
regulations assessment which is appended
to the report uh and overall the
recommendation is to approve the
application subject to conditions and
the adoption of the appro assessment at
Annex one thank
you thank you I move the officer's
recommendation is adopted can I have a
second please councelor K and uh does
anyone want to
speak councelor
Wing I can see they've uh consulted with
the Marine management organization and
and a marine license was was uh was
issued so I feel quite confident that
everything's in place to ensure that
that people and people in our
environment are as protected as they can
be during this this assessment I did
read at one point that that that some of
the construction might occur during the
nesting season but uh that but the works
will be Haled and and uh they'll they'll
ensure that birds are fledged before
before they uh re restart work so it
does seem that every that every little
every little bit is uh every little
thing is being taken into consideration
to to ensure uh that everybody's
protected and everything is
protected councelor bayford thank you
chair yes I agree entirely with councel
wing I think that um there's absolutely
no reason to refuse this application um
I think the there's a construction
management plan every um attempt seem uh
has been undertaken to protect the
environment so I'd like to support it
thank
you anyone else in that case I we will
now put the motion for the officer's
recommendation for approval to the vote
those in
favor
yeah that's carried thank
you so that concludes the public
speaking for this meeting councilor
Alburn um you have declared um an
interest before you go can I just ask
you if there are any other items on the
reserve list that you would wish to
reserve for speaking no okay if you
would just remain until we get to the
end no you you
leave you just remain
outside let me finish the sentence if
you remain outside um and then if
anything is reserved we can call you
back
in so um I once
the passes the threshold I can read this
bit I am I'm now calling call ING upon
the clerk to read out the remaining
planning applications if a member wishes
to reserve an application will they
please call out as the clerk reads thank
you thank you chair uh so we have
a47 Eastern esnard broadstairs yes pleas
A5 East Pier building East Pier Ramsgate
A6 East Pier uh sorry East Pier building
East Pier Ramsgate again A8 Brunswick
Hall uh hardw Street Rams skates and A9
Jackie Baker's recreational ground
Highfield Road Rams
Gates thank you can I have a proposer to
move that the applications that have not
been reserved be determined in
accordance with the officer's
recommendation councelor rattigan and a
seconder councelor
ke do members
agree thank you um so for the benefit of
the public I will call upon the Clark to
read out the applications that have been
determined
thank you chair so to confirm that's A5
East Pier building East Pier Ramsgate A6
East Pier building East Pier Ramsgate A8
Brunswick Hall hardress Street Ramsgate
and A9 Jackie Bakers recreational ground
Highfield Road Ramsgate thank you and
can someone attract councelor album to
come back in
please
I okay thank you um it's item A4 and I'm
going to ask for the officer to present
the
application thank you chair um so the
proposal is for the erection of a single
story side and rear extension at number
seven Eastern espan and also a two-story
out building to the rear so you can see
the property um marked by red on the
Google image here it's on the corner of
Eastern esade and Dickens Road
um so this is the site outlined in Red
so you can see that there are two points
of vehicle access at the site of the
moment one an access on Eastern esade
and one on Dickens
Road
so this is the front elevation of the
property on Eastern
esade uh and this is the existing Garage
on Dickens Road with the neighboring
property on Di Road in the image on the
right so just to show the relationship
between the um the development and uh
the neighboring property on Eastern
esade you can see that you've got the
distance on one side of the the boundary
and then another to the actual side
elevation of the the main
building um so this is a view now
looking towards the sea so we're looking
the the opposite angle that we were just
looking at so the application property
is on the left and the neighbor property
is on the right so you can see just at
the top of your image uh sorry top of
the above the fence here you can see
there's a a communal entrance which
accesses the flats in the neighboring
property there are three Flats uh which
um were approved a number of years ago
for a conversion of that
property uh and then you've got the
rear-facing windows in that property at
ground and first floor level and also a
roof
level uh this is a view a bit further
back showing that relationship again
uh and now we're going to just look at
the rear where the two-story out
building is
proposed uh so this is actually a view
from the existing first floor of um the
of number seven Eastern es looking down
towards the existing single story
structure and you can see the full depth
of the neighboring property on Dickens
Road uh and then in more closeup detail
uh you can see the existing relationship
there is a side window at the moment
that you can see obscured by the the
single story building just getting up
close it's an obscure glazed window so
it it's considered it's a a
non-habitable room window there in for
the side of the of the dwelling and then
this is a view further back to the left
the back left corner of of the property
showing you know the relationship with
the plot and the neighbor on Dickens
Road this is a view outside the existing
vehicle or access on Dickens Road from
where that that garage is currently
served um and okay so now if we look at
the propos itself so um as mentioned
there's a a side and rear extension
which wraps around the property there is
also um the creation of a Terrace area
at first floor which we'll look at on
the elevations and then there is a new
twostory out building at the rear uh
this has been slightly changed from it
the current location of the garage and
is set back by uh a number of meters
from the front it's the five MERS again
that we talked about earlier being set
back from the pavement on Dickens Road
so just having a look uh overall at the
floor plans um the existing is on the
left the proposed is on the right um so
to look at this in a bit more
detail just look at that front uh the
main building um so what you've got um
the Eastern explanat is at the top of
the screen um so you've got views when
we look at the elevations on on pretty
much every elevation of the extension
because it's the side and the rear so
you've got an outcrop here and then
there's a glazed link which is actually
set back from the frontage of the
property to link to this single story
side element and then the rear and side
element wraps around uh at the
back uh and then on the uh first floor
plan you can see that there's a lantern
light on the extension there's no
accommodation sorry there's no um
there's no balcony above the single
story element in the main bit of the
side but there is in part at the rear of
the the building itself and they've
created a Terrace propose now previously
this was larger it was amended as part
of the application um with the officer
securing amendments uh they they are
proposing to have a 1.8 m High um screen
along the side elevation to avoid
overlooking to the neighboring property
in eastern espan
a um and then this is the second floor
just showing a basically a reorientation
of existing accommodation within there
uh
existing so front elevation youve got a
couple of changes here not only have you
got this the actual extension but
they're also removing the existing um
enclosure around the balcony um so the
actual bay window that's at first floor
is there at the moment but the enclosure
around it that we saw on the photo has
been removed I mentioned about the
glazed link which is set back from the
frontage that's where the mouse pointer
is there and you you can see the front
elevation of the structure so we are in
an area um which has come over the
broadstairs neighborhood plan which is
the one of the seafront zones um and one
of the requirements of that just as it
is with our own policy qo2 which is to
make sure the materials are matching
that's what's been proposed in terms of
the facing materials uh as well as the
roof in terms of the side elevation so
this is the elevation actually on
Dickens Road um you've got uh the rear
extend ition part of that which comes
out where the access door out to the
Garden is um and then on the rear
elevation um so this is the elevation
that we saw with the image um looking
back towards towards the sea um you can
see that where that Terrace is at first
floor where the then you've got the 1.8
m High uh Timber loued guarding rail
which um to obscure the views to the
neighboring property uh as and this is
important to see that the relationship
with the neighboring property the bound
it's the development is uh in close
proximity to the boundary with the
property on Eastern esade um you're
looking at a height of of 2.5 m to the
Eevees height and then pitching away uh
from
that um so when you look at the next
elevation which is the elevation that
actually faces the neighboring property
now bear in mind obviously this spans
from the front all the way to the back
um in terms of when we looked to the
block plan the rear element here at at
ground floor is the area that needs to
be considered in terms of whether or not
it results in a sense of enclosure to
the neighboring property uh as mentioned
it's 2.5 m to the top of of the eaves
before it then pitches away from that
boundary um this is an idea of what the
timber L screen would look like to
restrict views out
um oh I've somehow pressed the right
Mouse button there we go um so in terms
of the relationship with the neighboring
property um to the south on Eastern
espan a because of the distance that
you've got from the property the
neighboring property to the boundary uh
the the sort of incursion further back
from the single store extension combined
with the 2.5 M he is considered to be
acceptable on the rear-facing windows in
that property it's a bedroom window at
ground floor as part of the conversion
but because it's set away and it's only
a single story structure it's considered
to be acceptable in terms of the
development at the rear so this um
Dickens Road is on the left and this is
now the ground floor plan uh where
you've got um you see the the garage
itself uh you've got the door that opens
into the the garden which then accesses
the top which is put forward to be a
home office so we've got the layer of
that so the red is actually showing
where you can actually get 2 m Headroom
actually head rooms um actually sort of
1.55 is the requirements there is a
actually a bit more available um one of
the issues that was raised um as as part
of the the consultation um was these are
the Doral windows in that out building
that face back towards the back
elevation of the main property uh these
have been conditioned or would be
conditioned to be fitted with obscure
glass because you would get views back
into the neighboring property because of
the relationship that you've got so
that's a requirement of um any
permission were to be granted
this is the front elevation of the
garage fronting Dickens
Road uh and then this is the the um west
elevation um facing the neighbor and to
show you the relationship with the
neighboring property I'm just going to
click through you can see they've got
rainwater storage uh as part of that out
building this is the the the street
scene um so this was something
specifically that we felt we needed to
get to get an idea of how related to The
Bungalow that you've got next door um it
is considered that there is a separation
distance there as I mentioned earlier
there isn't any impact on side windows
of the property on Dickens Road um but
the main consideration here is the the
visual impact um because it's set away
from the neighbor um and it's it's
doesn't compete in terms of its Ridge
height and it pitches away it's
considered that the design of it was to
you know is is considered acceptable
from our perspective so overall it is
considered to be a ordance with the the
character area character appearance
policies in both the broad neighborhood
plan and the thanet local plan as well
as with the changes that have been made
in the safeguarding conditions it would
uh Safeguard the um living conditions of
neighboring properties so it is
recommended for approval thank you
chair anyone to speak got Council
Garner thank you um I just have a
question about the out
building sorry I'm missed a bit I've
just move I've just I've just realized
my apologies um move that the officer
recommendation is approved first um and
seconded by Council of matterface sorry
and then people to speak I got councilor
Garner thank you as I indicated I just
have a question about the out building
I've I've looked at
um uh the report and there's condition
six States the use of the out building
hereby approved shall be limited to
purposes andery to the needs and
personal enjoyment of the occupants of
the dwelling and shall at no time be
used for Independent Business or
commercial purposes so I'm just seeking
confirmation that my assumption is
correct here that the OCC the um
residents are not allowed to use that as
either a holiday lit Airbnb or anything
along those
lines yeah that that is that is correct
yeah it's it's that would be um a a a
distinct um use in the sense of not
being ancillary or incidental is the
requirement usually in in the legal term
so yeah that would preclude that because
I know there have been a number of other
planning applications that have been
granted like this where the applicants
have then come back and sort the remove
approval of condition six in this case
one two or three and others to allow for
the use of the annex so in this case
we're not allowing for that and um
obviously we have to take every planning
application as it comes but we're quite
clear in this case that it isn't used
for an Airbnb or holid DEET like a
number of the other properties up
Dickens Road thank you councelor ratkin
yeah um I think uh the the plan officers
covered all the basis uh of sort of you
know with the uh sort of uh what do you
call it skir uh uh glazing uh regards to
not being able to use it for sort of
Airbnb holiday so I think it's a nice a
nice design um yeah and I would support
it councelor m face wanted to say that
the garage that door and that window is
very traditional a lot of the properties
in that area have got garages not
necessarily with a home office but I
think the garage is very much in keeping
with the rest of Dickens Road and with
the
esade counc bford thank you chair yes I
mean I feel this is a very Pro prominent
location and needed to be looked at very
carefully thank you very much for the
detailed report um I think that the uh
overlooking and loss of privacy to
neighbors has been addressed very
carefully I think materials are suitable
uh with matching materials and I I think
I'm quite happy for this to go ahead
thank
you and how do we ensure that the
obscured glass is um remains in place
add INF for
item we enforce condition five which
would require that uh they've got the
Obscure glass has got to be permanently
retained thereafter is is one of the
requirements so if it was to be removed
then there'd be in breach of that
condition and we would serve a breach
condition notice on it been in 20 years
time if we're all still
here hope thank
you in which case um I put the officer's
recommendation for approval to the vote
those in
favor and were there any abstentions or
against and that's
carried right in that case
uh that's the end that's the end so I've
lost me bit my bit on the sheet of paper
that says good night so but thank you
very much
and and good
night thank
you
for